[Music]
[Music]
why would you bet on goliath when we got
bet david valuetainment giving
[Music]
[Music]
we're live episode 172
with uh our friend here adam sosnick we
have uh vinnie osana in the house
tyler's sitting on the sidelines but
he's always very helpful and a special
guest today
who's a very very unique special
uh guest you'll see why while we go
through it you're going to be confused a
lot but you're going to get a lot of
clarity
and uh but she's cool as hell uh batiya
ungar sargon to the entire syrian
community that's been texting me and
dming me i mean when i say entire syrian
community i'm talking like 19 of them
that have messaged me and you my mom is
she a syrian yeah she is not a syrian
she's not we were disappointed prior to
the podcast she's not sorry and she's
also not a palestinian jew
according to the disinformation camp on
social media
uh adam she's she's part of my people
y'all yeah so you assyrians cannot claim
part of the jewish tribe but be honest
with you
palestinian jewish
automatically i was like that household
must have been divided oh my god right
like like the gaza strip she's like you
stay on your side we'll be on this side
don't argue with yourself loves me
she hates me vinnie needs five percent
down by the way so it's already
happening her book uh bad news how woke
media is undermining democracy here's
what's interesting she's a she's a
marxist who thinks
trump is more of a marxist yeah and
sanders than maybe the aocs of the world
who knows maybe [ __ ] so yeah so again
like i said it's very confusing but
we've got a lot of topics to go through
yeah so we're gonna have a good time so
how you doing thank you so much for
having me yeah it's great to have you on
honor to be here with you yeah well it's
it's the pleasures uh ours to have you
on and uh we're we're happy to have you
do you mind taking a moment you know
you're a deputy editor i think with
newsweek and newsweek is uh coming up
just ten years ago five years ago
newsweek was just newsweek but the last
few years both sides are kind of willing
to
when a publication is is pissing off
both sides and attracting both sides i
think they're doing a good job and i
think that's what newsweek's been doing
the last couple years so if you don't
mind taking a couple minutes here and
just kind of introducing yourself to the
audience your background a little bit
about the book and we'll get right into
it yeah i'm batianga sargon i'm a deputy
opinion editor at newsweek um exactly
like you said we run opinion from across
the political spectrum which means we
make everybody angry uh but everybody
deserves a fair hearing and that's
that's what we're here to do to fight
cancel culture and
it's just it's such a unique thing to do
i mean it used to be that like that was
the mission statement of the new york
times and that is clearly no longer the
mission statement of the new york times
and so you know that's what we're doing
and um it's really an honor to be part
of a great team there um let me tell you
something interesting though
so um newsweek now is considered
center right
not because we have more right wing
opinion we don't we actually have three
kind of left-wing liberal opinion
editors and two on the right but because
the very idea of hosting opinion from
across the political spectrum is now
coded
as a right-wing conservative proposition
how crazy is that according to who
though that's the question right so
people there they're sort of like
websites that tell you like where yeah
i've seen this on the spectrum yeah
exactly and that's so nuts because the
left used to be the side of like let's
hear from everybody open minded open
debate and now the left is the side of
like no if you don't agree with me you
don't get a hearing because you know you
know silence is violence words are
violence right and it's now considered a
conservative thing if you want to hear
from both sides but wouldn't it be more
uh centric you're right yeah i think
we're center yeah i think we're dead
center you know but but um people will
say now oh newsweek has gone to the
right and what they mean by that is not
that we have more conservative op-eds
what they mean is we're willing to hear
from both sides and that's too much how
dare you how dare you have both
perspectives
what is wrong with you a lot of you know
reporting fox same thing cnn everybody
you can't say you're not biased
everybody i don't care how you're
reporting it but is it you think because
newsweek is more of the point that we're
just going to state this is the facts
this is the news and and they're not
being like weapons i mean they're not
being like political political
operatives you know what i mean they're
just the news is the news and here it is
yeah and i think it's more even like in
the opinion section we're saying look we
want you to make up your mind so we're
gonna have the left wing view on this
and the right wing view on this and
everything in between because you're
smart enough to make up your own mind
i'm not going to tell you what to think
i'm going to say this is what these
people think this is what these people
think and you the american people are
smart enough to know which of those
makes more sense do you believe that
though yeah that the american people are
smart enough to make up their own minds
yes you don't
some uh a hutzpah who's by the house
some you know some like to just kind of
live in their echo chamber even if you
tell them yeah you guys are not populist
that's the thing because you guys made a
bunch of money and so you know you're
smarter than everybody else i don't know
about it i'm just a journalist so i'm
like i'm not smarter than anybody else
you know well most journalists would not
agree with you right now most
journalists according to you exactly are
a little bit more on the yeah wokey
elite side of things these days but but
listen that's actually a very good
debate to say
you know can people think for themselves
and and
decipher whether a thing is good or not
you know process an issue for themselves
because you know i think uh
mainstream media many politicians are
banking on majority people being dumb
and they talk to people as if they're
dumb and they're not like the other day
one of the reporters went up to
president biden and said hey how do you
feel about the fact that your
disapproval rating is at 94
with voters under the age of 30. and he
just came up and he said that's not true
that's not true that's not true
92 percent of democrats said they would
vote for me again to run for office and
there is no data anywhere saying 92
of democrats would vote for biden but
that is an element of saying listen
voter i think you're dumb and i think
you're gonna believe me and i think
because if i keep saying it you're gonna
say okay cool maybe 92 percent do think
he's doing a good job and you know
people are going to vote for him so
there isn't there is an argument there
about the fact that but i do i don't
think it's the dumb i think what i would
say adam is the lazy
i think i think voters are lazy to go do
their own research that's the challenge
i actually don't agree with you on the
lazy i think it has to do with focus
again most people are just working
taking care of their families taking
care of their kids they're trying to pay
the bills like they're so focused on
everything else in life and then when
they time they get home they watch
reality tv they watch a sports game and
they crack open up crazy
not even lazy it's just like maybe lazy
is a different interpretation yes i'm
not even born in america you had a 4.2
gpa you don't know the meaning of lazy i
i say this all the time you can invest
your time or you can you can bring up
the dictionary for this guy please no
definitely get lazy
has this thing gotten with adam that we
have to define lazy sure pull it up
please
unwilling to work or use energy i think
they're willing to work i think they're
willing to use energy you need work for
their jobs people need you but out of
work you're right out of work you're
right they want to spend their time
perfect not investing so when it comes
down to wanting to learn more about
politics and policies they're somewhat
lazy that's what we're saying and i
think we disagree here
you're disagreeing on the definition
buddy hey okay so but by the way this is
good because adam's in the disagreeing
mode so that we can get this thing
really something
but i have to admit i disagree with you
also let's go on the lazy side tell me
why go back um you know two-thirds of
americans are living paycheck to
paycheck they are so
stressed out they don't know if they
should take the 50 they have left in
their bank account and use it to buy
meat for dinner for their kids for maybe
the last time this month or use it to
fill up the gas so they can take the
kids to church on sunday people are
struggling and the idea that they should
care about politics
at this moment to me just i'm i'm with
them like they're right these
politicians want us talking about them
and defending them because that's their
career they want poor americans
struggling working-class americans to be
spending their time beefing up
representing them instead of the other
way around so i'm kind of with adam on
this i feel like um it's just it's a and
i'm so i really want to talk about this
with you guys because like the view that
i have like i'm i'm now working on my
next book which is about the working
class and so i'm spending all my time
that i'm not working for newsweek
interviewing people working with them in
their trucks with them you know you know
working stand by side by side with them
and the struggle is real and these
people are not lazy these people work 13
14 15 hours a day and they're always
treading water and so i really at some
point want to get into it with you guys
like about like if you think that your
success really is totally
duplicable and like you know the things
that get in the way of people being able
to achieve what you have like i do
and by the way i will defend the lazy
argument and i'll push back let me
explain to you why
if you know every show on netflix and
you're broke you have a problem you're
lazy if you know every hit song that
comes out and you're broke you're lazy
if you know every single post on social
media of other people's lives and you
don't have another hustle that you're
working you have to accept the fact that
you're lazy let me explain to you let me
go a little bit deeper with this on my
own personal life
my hip hop
music stops in o3
i'm being that serious
mine stops in o3 my night life stops in
o3
my chasing of women doing the way i did
stopped in o3
my desire to want to watch and consume
every single sporting event that i never
missed a lakers game from the moment i
came to the states and when i joined the
army boot camp obviously you can watch
tv but then afterwards i've never missed
a laker game from the age of being 12
years old coming to the states to the
age of being 24 years old 23 years old
lakers was my religion sports stats was
my religion and i was broke and my dad
kept having heart attacks and my dad
worked at a 99 cent store on manchester
and normandy while i'm working at bally
60 hours a week i'm working at bally's
i'm the top sales guy at values because
i wanted my dad to be done but i
couldn't make enough money i was making
three grand a month
but at the time when i was off
i wasn't working a side business
i was doing anything to entertain myself
we are fooling ourselves if we're going
to sit there and just put all the
responsibility on the people who have
succeeded and not put any responsibility
on the folks at the bottom that we're
going to say well poor you
you're working so hard but then how do
you know so much about all these shows i
don't understand i've never watched this
montage what is this montana show what
what is this
yellowstone i don't even know what y'all
i don't know what yellowstone is i've
never watched the breaking bat i've
never watched the sopranos i've never
watched an episode of sopranos the only
serious i've ever watched from o3 till
today is house of cards season one
because people kept telling me i gotta
watch it
so as much as we want to sit there
and say oh my gosh poor me poor this
poor that which i come from a family
where half of them were communist and
half of them were imperialists the one
on the communist side that's all they
ever talked about their bible was
communist manifesto and the ones on the
right they kept saying you know
why don't you do something every time it
was more fun for me to talk to the
communists than it was to talk to the
conservatives because the communist
would feel sorry for me and it was safe
and it was warm it was faster it was so
much better every time i went to the
communist oh my gosh you know it's them
i'm like that's right
you're right and i would feel special
but every time i want to talk to these
suckers on the other side the
conservatives say what are you doing
about it why don't you make a change why
don't you pick up a book why don't you
get another job why not [ __ ] you
don't understand this is unfair
eventually i'm 23 years old looking at
my bank account broke
and i said which philosophy do you want
to buy into pat which one do you want to
buy to then i chose so now
is there things on the leader side
that's happening as well sure but for us
to fool ourselves thinking people don't
have any options to make a change
wait
you skipped over the most important part
okay so you chose you did so what how
did you get from bally's to here like
walk me through that i went into
military and i got some discipline for
two and a half years because i didn't
have it thank you for your service no
any time so i gotta i needed it so i
think many boys who are undecided
military's a good choice for them
i got out when i got out i worked at
ballets while i'm working at bally's a
guy named robbie solomon and my sister
my sister recommended me to read the
book how to win friends and influence
people
keep in mind i hate books till 21 years
old
anybody who knows me from high school
they know i've never finished the book
cover to cover never i've never finished
a book i've never finished uh
what is it of mice of men
i never finished the uh
uh uh
nelly petting as a lenny lenny was
letting the rats have my son
facebook
that he didn't fit what's the one that
was then this this 1984 okay no no
fahrenheit 451 are you saying the books
they assigned
uh listen i've never
finished a book cover to cover
never until 21
and robbie said read how to master the
art of selling by tom hopkins and i did
and then my sister said how to win
friends and influence people it's a good
book to read i read those two books when
i read those two books
i sat there and i said
this information is in a book for 10
bucks holy [ __ ]
what other recommendation you got next
one next one rich dad poor that you know
psycho cybernetics you know power versus
force and i kept reading reading reading
reading reading reading reading green
and i'm like this information is insane
then i started realizing i'm making way
too many excuses
i'm blaming the world for my problems
i'm not taking any responsibility some
of the mindsets that my mother's side
gave me is right some of it isn't right
some of the mindsets that my dad gave me
is right some of it isn't right i
stopped questioning things and i said
listen
if i want my life to change i got to
make a decision about it my parents
brought me here
to be free my dad gave me work ethic and
next thing you know i start uh
uh uh uh i'm dating a girl named jean
veer who's working on morgan stanley
dean witter
and uh i said so why is it that you know
you have all these nice cars and she
says well i work at morgan stanley dean
what else how can i get a job there
uh-huh she says you need to go to ucla i
said i'm not going to school
she said they're not going to hire you i
said i'm not going to go to college she
says you're not going to work out morgan
stanley dean witter i said let me see if
i can find a creative way to get a job
so i went and printed my resume okay and
i put a cover letter with a nice joke
getting creative
i faxed the 200 places goldman merrill
smith barney uh td waterhouse morgan all
of these places
i got 30 callbacks 15 of them left
because the joke was funny yeah the
other 15 offered me an interview
three gave me offers at 21 years old i
started working on morgan stanley dean
witter a day before 9 11. jeez
so let's let's see let's see people
there didn't have a college degree
no you you were the only one sure okay
so how good was that joke
wait a minute what was the joke wait a
minute but wait a minute i really want
to know where you go from here yeah i
really want to know where you go but we
got to hear the joke first yeah yeah we
gotta hear this i tell you the joke the
joke was a father has three sons he
tells us three sons when i die i want
you to drop
a thousand dollars in the uh what do you
call it the kids get grave when i'm
dying in front of family you have to
show how much you love your father okay
first son drops 100 bills okay second
son drops 20 50 bills third one is a
financial advisor
he cuts a check for three thousand
dollars take the cash and walks away
that's brilliant
but what do you say to that i'm curious
any there there you know the job did i
have it because of my last name because
i'm special because i'm smart because of
how did i get that job
so
so
like
they don't hire people she was right
right like she wasn't wrong they don't
hire people without a college degree
which is terrible by the way because you
learn nothing at college the only thing
you learn in college is to have contempt
for the working class like to have
contempt for people who don't have a
college degree so this is not a
pro-college argument this is like an
anti-morgan stanley argument that they
insist that people have this credential
just for their own prestige right it has
nothing to do with what you learn there
but anyway setting that aside their
choice they're right they a lot of
companies don't implement that rule
though it's changed since then this
changes slowly especially the big tech
company yeah totally tech is is good on
this front only the front button
cut that clip up real quick yeah
supported that happened um but um
so the the i don't have to have an
explanation for it i mean i assume it
has something to do with your charisma
and the force of your personality and
the something unique that that was a
that was first conveyed through that
cover letter and then in interviews
which i think you know like i think
you're being a little bit like i
disagree consciously naive but because
because the fact that you're the only
one who did it right like the fact that
you're the only one who managed to do it
i disagree i'm not the only one that did
it
my friend steve avedyan was another 1.8
gpa guy he came out he was you know
doing nothing he was helping out as that
as a truck driver him and his buddy
alfred
decide to go being truck drivers you
tell me who's a truck driver they were
nobodies like oh they're gonna make it
in business no four year no two year no
nothing they're running a 300 million
dollar transportation business today
so i can i can go on all of these
stories
to say hey
let's keep feeling sorry for everybody
there's a big difference between
sympathy empathy and trying to rise up
now i know i agree with you i don't want
to come off as someone who's like oh you
should all feel sorry i don't want to
come off that way okay we're on the same
page there they don't feel that way like
they're proud of their work they feel
that it is
i think i think what they're doing is
also very something they should be proud
of okay so that i guess that would be my
next question would be like
like someone has to be the person who is
the custodial staff right who's not
going to make it big right someone has
to be the person who is stalking the
shelves at the supermarket right we all
rely on the label it's a choice of of of
but we we need them we need
no one's judging them right but i'm
saying so because we need them yeah
we should be invested in those jobs
granting dignity and a living wage
because we need them to not be and we do
in this job or in this job and we do
right so but i'm but like but from their
point of view they're struggling oh yeah
and they are struggling and i and by the
way i i i what's the answer to that yeah
but but why don't we see why are they
struggling
because you can't live on 15 an hour in
new york city but but why are they
struggling though why are they
struggling though is it just is your
argument only they can't make it on 50
bucks an hour the housing market
okay so why do we have that rh is a big
part of it actually you talk about this
a lot okay so so okay so but why are
let's actually dissect oh yeah okay why
are there why is there say i'm gonna
write it down i'm gonna write notes so
tell me why they're struggling i'm gonna
take notes i'll be the student
insulate
guys i hope you understand like this is
why the audience likes these types of
conversations i love it and this is why
i have so much respect for you that you
you don't you go anywhere and talk to
anybody and you love me
by the way i have a very serious weight
question for you i know i'm going to
wait
up here stay there
so why are they here
um why why are they struggling
so so um there's sort of three tiers of
people in let's say what we would call
labor the working class right the top
tier is not struggling at all cops
electricians plumbers like there's a lot
of dignity in those jobs right now
they're well
paid they make a living wage and a lot
of them are able to afford their own
homes especially if they live in red
states where housing is not the same as
it is are you talking about the working
class blue collar jobs here if you will
okay so that's the upper echelon which
degree you aren't rich upper echelon of
working classes fantastic a lot of
government employees exactly um yeah
exactly yeah okay um
then you have the middle tier who are
people who
like they are they're not poor
and i wouldn't even say they're
struggling they're not like lying awake
at night how am i gonna pay for this or
that although right now it's very
difficult because of inflation but
that's a very it's a unique situation
right now their biggest struggle is they
do not have access to the american dream
because they cannot they're not going to
be home owners in their lifetime and we
know that owning a home is how you
transfer that wealth to the next
generation right what's sort of a
classic standard for like how we what we
call like middle class life right and
who are these people what type of job a
lot of truckers are in this position
this is people who are making between 40
and 60 65 you know um what retail truck
drivers
one lower i would say so yeah so so
truckers you know um um people who are
you know let's say in um you know the
trades often you know if they're not
maybe editors and uh
and graphic designer types
um a lot of people in the bottom layer
of the tech industry you know um these
are people who are making like i said
between 40 and 60. if you're making 60
and you're living in new york you'll
never own a home right if you're making
40 and you're living here would probably
be difficult as well and then you've got
that bottom tier of people who we
all of these people are people who
lo whose labor we rely on to exist right
like we rely on them not deciding to
become an entrepreneur and make a
million dollars so that they no longer
have to do these jobs just as a society
we rely on them right who are these
bottom runners
are people who are in retail people who
are cashiers
3.5 million people are our cashiers you
know three million retail associates in
america fast food workers right now it
happens to be that even though the
federal minimum wage is 7.25 an hour 759
an hour most of these people now are
making
between 12 and 15. the problem is is
that in many of the places
that is not a living wage that is
basically poverty wages you know so
where i live i live in brooklyn i
actually don't live in like one of the
most expensive neighborhoods i live in
an immigrant neighborhood it's sort of
more reasonable but still the guy who
delivers my amazon packages will never
would never dream of owning yeah but are
these people immigrants what is there
any data of who these people are
who is like this lower third it's a
little who are they
are they just naturally born americans
or just strive to be a mcdonald's worker
i doubt it the question of which tier
you end up in is very interesting
what it seems to me like and this is
something pat you've brought up on your
show is that one of the number one
predictors of whether you end up in the
bottom
is whether you come from a single mother
family and whether you are a single
mother or a single parent because we
know that marriage is very tightly
correlated with higher earnings and
economists don't know exactly why that
is but it's quite hard to be poor if
you're married i mean that's just a
weird phenomenon of american life that
nobody wants to talk about you're saying
it's hard to be poor if you're married
married men
let me give you a statistic okay because
this is really this blew my mind
so the median income is around forty
four thousand dollars a year right
um the median income for a black male
head of household who's who's not
married is 33 000 a year
the median income for a black male head
of household who's married
is 93 000 a year which is not a sneak
nobody who's making that is struggling
you know
that's a person who's living a
middle-class life so the the answers are
not oh you should feel sorry for these
people right the question is how do we
get more people from the bottom into the
higher rungs but again like i said like
some of that labor right fast food
workers right
we rely on that we rely on there being
people to but but stay there though so
so let me ask you a question the
population today is what 7.9 billion
yeah okay
uh how long did it take us to double
that population
60 years 60 years ago we were at 3.6
billion
how long did it take us to double that
3.6 billion to 1.8 billion
40 50 years prior to that we have 1.8
billion i can co keep going back and
back and write okay
the idea
of a person staying where they're at
everything in life is about graduating
okay
what's graduating
one should not stay in a position
forever without graduating to the next
level we should grow and we should
create an environment where people are
developing and increasing the level of
contribution to society that's me i
worked at burger king i wanted to be a
cashier they never made me a cashier i
worked as a chef i was a cook i made
waffles
burger king i bragged about it i was a
chef they gave me a medium shirt and i
was six one you could see my lower back
my guys were coming to laugh at me no
joke my friends know exactly what i'm
talking about can i just say you are
amazing like you're so cool what you've
been through and like what you've
achieved like it's very cool like your
story is very inspiring i appreciate
that thank you but also for me
everything that's inspiring to me i look
at guys like
what life he lived and how he became who
he is today from sleeping on the couch
as a comedian to having made it in the
insurance business and nothing in his
background says about good for him i see
him from going from military to them
becoming a comedian next thing you know
he's on deaf comedy jam and he made it
but by the way you know a lot of us have
that story of going from nothing to
making it making it doesn't mean being a
billionaire yesterday i was having a
call with uh
uh a penguin we're launching uh the next
business book and you know how you're
talking to publishers and you're going
through a book title like well you know
we have to talk about the book title is
and a part of yesterday's conversation
was i said the most important question
to ask is who do you want to be in life
what do you mean i said listen
you don't have to be bezos
basers wanted to be bezos you don't have
to be musk you don't have to be a
millionaire but who do you want to be in
life the moment you know who you want to
be in life go solve for that
what's not healthy is if you chose to
live a regular life and you're envious
of somebody else that chose to live a
bigger life
the life of a bigger life isn't a better
life right it's not an attractive life a
lot of people only see what happens 20
30 years later nobody wants to see what
happened those five 10 15 years while
they were not there at any of the events
it's called the iceberg it sucks
it sucks so guess how many people want
to go through the 10 15 20 year period
not many man
it is horrible it's tough it's scary
costs marriages relationship family time
fun party and all that stuff this whole
concept of winning at a higher level
sucks now
if somebody says well i don't want to go
through it no one should judge them
no problem you're right you can go and
contribute at any levels that you want
but the question i ask you is why are
those people in the situation they're in
what policy caused them to be in the
situation they're in and who created
those policies yeah
that's the problem yeah okay so if we
keep printing the money and throwing
money to poor and then wondering i'm
against that yeah you're against it i'm
against it as well against that i'm
against welfare okay you're against
welfare yeah because they make the
working class support the poor i hate
that so how do so how do we so how do we
lift up the middle class what's your way
of lifting up the money so that is the
that's that's the question i'm curious
so each tier needs different things you
know like this so the top tier like they
need respect what do cops need from us
right now big time respect they freaking
need our respect because they're out
there getting shot and killed and they
can't do their jobs and the criminals
aren't scared of them anymore yeah you
know this is a job that every american
relies on and the elites sit there and
they smear people they smear these
people who are out there giving their
lives to defend them it makes me crazy
we're on the same page right um union um
high-skilled trades these are great jobs
what do they need they need our respect
they need the next generation of people
who are good with their hands and
intelligent and smart to have a pathway
to that vocational schools we don't have
any vocational schools the idea that
this is a respectable job so that kids
who are coming from you know
who are not good at school maybe you
know that they have access to that
version of the american group so the top
tier really means very little right they
don't need anything from us they don't
need anything from the government that's
for sure right you're saying the top
tier of the working class yes yes
exactly yeah it's by the way it's it's a
very very good point one of the best
books on marriage is
love and respect i don't know if you've
ever read the book of love and respect
shout out to the authors it's a great
book that if you're married you may want
to read it if you think about getting
married you ought to read it talk about
what men need and what women need you
know the understanding that men just
sometimes need what
just respect me man that's what i need
you and then women need love but i
understand what the point you're making
right there okay what else can we do to
lift these guys out out of poverty
because right now statistic came out
which concerns me the most
do you know
in the last
70 years
what the average property value yeah has
been compared to your income let me ask
this question one more time so for
example if you make 60 grand a year
and that's the average income in america
household income you know what the
average property value has been
based on that sixty thousand dollars of
your income like what they're buying as
a house give me the give me the times
like three times four times five times
six times eight times ten times like
what do you think the average has been
is it like are you understand this
question yes okay so what do you think
that has is it like a five hundred
thousand dollar house compared to a
sixty thousand dollar so no so let me
ask a question one more time if the
average historically in the last 70
years okay
if the average american makes 60 grand a
year
how many times their income is the
average home value in america seven so
so so
50 years ago i think it was about two
now i think it's more the you know the
average house now sells for 300 000. so
300 000 is how many times 60. six times
more six seven say six or seven five
times six three divided by sixty so
here's here's where it is historically
it's been five
we've hit two or three
we've never in the last 70 years gone
above seven it is eight times today
you tell me how the hell middle america
can't afford that exactly so you're
making 60 grand what's your answer to
that well so what what happened with
that what is the problem with that well
i
i mean i think elizabeth warren is right
about this the problem is women entering
the workforce and driving up the course
she talked about that years ago she
ain't talking about that today yeah
she's talking about that today
when she talked about 20 years ago but
you're saying your problem is that women
have entered the workforce and that's
been a bad thing for society it's been a
bad thing for the middle class that's
for sure because you don't sound very
pro-feminist
i think being mars means that you're not
quite you're not i mean i would consider
myself feminist i think women should
have the choice but most women who are
working it's not women like me because
they're like addicted to their jobs and
it gives them meaning and self-esteem
they're working at walmart or they're
you know what i mean they're working
because they have to support their
family because a man can no longer
afford to support a family on a single
what should those women be doing then
they should have a choice
i mean they should have a choice i think
a lot of women would would like to raise
their children but instead of having
that we have a welfare state that's
trying to make free pre-k again trying
to make working-class people pay
taxes so their women could go work at
were forced to work at walmart instead
of staying home yeah but but those women
i get it from k you know from zero to
five you know stay home raise the kids
but once the kids are in middle school
high school you don't need to stay home
and take care of your kids anymore right
so but that's again it's like could they
then have you know a part-time option
what elizabeth warren are the hell are
they gonna do with their time if they're
just sitting around all day cleaning
um you know so you're saying this is a
very big argument that she's making and
it's very important
very important you know for you was your
mom working when you were kid when you
were from born to 18 yeah the entire
time yeah she had a job all those years
she was a full-time part-time teacher
and then she was a nurse and she's been
doing the same time or part time full
fulfilled full-time what did your dad do
he was a businessman so maybe people
call it a shady businessman but we won't
go there however he was working oh my
god i love that that's that's our
people's that's our heritage you know
that's our heritage
that's our heritage yeah but women this
is a tr like you're a person who
loves and respects and finds meaning in
their work right but you're saying that
most women don't they have to sacrifice
their livelihoods just to put food on
the table what's your argument for women
saying like there's this there's this
messed up thing now where what the
leftist elites want right build back
better wanted to charge
take taxpayer dollars from working-class
families right to give them free pre-k
there's something messed up about that
because
a lot of these women right would rather
stay home and raise their own kids
they're like you can't do that you have
to work and then pay taxes and we'll
take that money you make while you're
working and we'll raise your kids right
i think that's super messed up but i
want to come back to housing what do you
think caused the housing what do you
think caused it to be eight times
you know the income and how do we fix it
okay so do you guys know the difference
between quantitative easing and
tightening
do you know the difference no if you
want me okay my head to pop off my head
pad have been like please as an
economist can you tell us the difference
you know listen i'm a respectable guy
i'll give you the floor so you could
because i
quantum leap i saw a show once called
quantum leap i don't even know you sure
you don't want to break down
quantitative easing
and mortgage backers
let me just simplify it okay by the way
i'm going to explain it to you in the
simplest way that you'll be able to
teach it to anybody moving forward okay
you ever had a credit card yep okay
quantitative easing
is when american express visa mastercard
calls you and tells you your credit
limit has gone from five thousand
dollars to fifteen thousand dollars
congratulations to you
quantitative easing is when visa
mastercard calls you and tells you your
credit limit has gone from fifteen
thousand to five thousand dollars
did you understand the difference okay
no quantitative
quantitative easing is five becomes
fifteen thousand gotcha which means
guess what adam go spend more money yeah
we got your back that's not your money
but we'll let you spend more money wow
quantitative tightening is listen look
we are seeing your spending habits we're
taking ten thousand back your credit
limit is only five thousand
for the longest time in the since oh
wait whatever the timeline has been with
quantitative easing let's bail all these
big guys out
the more we build people out
the more they've sat around saying oh
it's okay man my dad is going to bail me
out oh my dad is going to bail me out do
whatever you want bro daddy's going to
bill you like 100 my daddy's going to
build me up my daddy's going to bail me
out my dad is going to build me on
it's time to stop building these bigger
companies they're too big to fail today
when we're going to quantitative
tightening
every single month their plan is to take
95 billion dollars of credit off the
table
so what does this mean the government's
gonna say hey mr bank xyz
you had this much now we're lowering it
and every month we're taking 95 billion
dollars off the table okay they're
tightening
the economy
we have not experienced this ever
in the history of america we tried
quantitative tightening briefly in 2008
for maybe a couple months the market
crashed when we tried quantitative
timing no no no here he go here put some
more money into the market feed more
money into the market
when they did that they bailed out the
guys at the top the guys at the top got
richer middle america the division got
wider now we got people that can't
afford to buy a house that's eight times
their income what the hell are you gonna
do keep increasing the minimum wage
that's not the strategy on what to do
that's not the solution to do that so
we're about to go through quantitative
tightening and i hope this next phase
that we go through
they don't get in the way of these
companies going out of business
the part about capitalism that i love is
the following and this one wait can we
before we move on from this let me make
this point and you can go to it this is
the part because i didn't understand
totally but yeah go ahead but this is
the part the part i love about
capitalism is is four freedoms
you have the freedom to buy
you have the freedom to sell
we have the freedom to try
and last but not least which some people
don't like we have the freedom to fail
oh i love that isn't that awesome i
didn't come up with it founding fathers
no no no that was all you
have to spend
freedom to sell freedom to try and the
freedom to fail we have to let the too
big to fail
fail yes it's that simple and we've
stopped that the last 15 years
you know what's even scarier do you know
the history that america
do you know in the history of america
okay
since the the great depression do you
even practice that 1850s do you know
what's the longest time america's ever
gone without a recession
when do you think it is you ready today
14 years
no way yes
we've had recessions every five to seven
years and they last six months to 43
months we have gone 14 years without a
recession
desperately not in a negative way we
desperately need a recession whoa we
desperately need a recession is that
because of um because of uncle trump
no
the economic expansion was 129 months
prior to
the 129 months of economic expansion
that we had started in oh wait
so that exactly the last recession so
you got to go from bush to obama to
obama to trump too so but people think
that kovid was a recession it was just a
brief blip on like a drop
back up because of quantitative easing
and money printing and i bet not to cut
you off but so do you think that because
this administration isn't admitting like
hey guys like it's really bad right now
it's happening they're just getting like
the elastic band guys this is not a
democratic thing or republican thing
because during this economic expansion
that we've had
we had a year of bush left but when did
obama get elected okay
oh wait can you can you pull up exactly
what monta the 128-month economic
expansion started i think it's like
sometime in norway so it's obama obama
trump biden
you got
three you got two three democrats terms
is what i'm not saying three democrats
you got three democrats you got one
republican okay and what did all of them
pretty much do let's print to bail out
what month did it start
one month did it start june overnight is
it june of 09
okay who was the president of june of
online because obama took office in
january of oh now
so economic the greatest economic
expansion
just so you know but yeah started under
obama
you're so smart i'm not smart i'm
telling you i'm not figure all this out
i'm not smart i've never heard anyone
say this and all i do all day is watch
the news no no i'm not i'm not cause
you're dealing with politicians and
people focus on politics not business
literally like all right
we're changing everything i'm just gonna
just take notes no no your twitter
but but the point wait wait wait wait
wait i you have to walk me through this
walk me through easing tightening and
exactly how that took housing prices and
made them higher i missed that link and
that i can't walk out of here without
knowing okay so so think about like if
if i'm buying uh a bad paper okay okay
so imagine if uh there's a bunch of
defaults uh uh and you're the bank
you're like hey man bail us out don't
worry give us all the shitty paper we'll
buy it
because you know when let's just say i'm
a small little uh a bank
and i got 10 million bucks okay
if i'm 10 million dollar bank and i take
500 000 home loans how many home loans
can i get 20 of them right because i'm
giving that loan but let's just say if i
get 10 houses i uh uh finance
that's how much money that's 5 million
bucks okay
i don't keep that
five million bucks i go to the bank and
i sell it
and i make a percent or two or whatever
the percentage on me selling the paper
to somebody else
for years they've been buying paper
nobody gives a [ __ ] if it's good or bad
paper
okay that's the whole big short
principle right don't worry about it
we'll buy the paper just send it to us
we'll send this and all of a sudden
they're like we're no longer buying it
wait what
no no we're no long china's we're no
longer buying it what do you mean you're
no longer buying it we're no longer
buying it oh [ __ ] we have to build these
banks out because they're no longer
buying it so if you don't allow people
to fail
and you keep getting in their way of
failing you're not allowing the pruning
process to come through so you're saying
in a natural situation
the price of the houses would be
determined by how much money a bank had
and was able to guarantee in terms of a
mortgage
but the price went up
because
another bank was willing to buy
that bank's mortgage that it gave is
that the argument then no no
quantity it's like fake money was
entered into the market to not prevent
those big companies to prevent those big
companies from going out of business
fake money right so it's it's kind of
like
but how exactly did that impact the
price of a house
how did it impact the if a price of the
house yeah how did that drive the prices
out there is more money circulating in
the marketplace oh i see so it's like an
inflation argument yeah the more money
everything costs more because there's
more money okay
income didn't go up right so so
that's you can't you gotta let the
market fail
you like okay so the principal do you
have any kids no okay i got four of them
right okay i'm trying to figure out what
the hell is going on with this parenting
stuff i'm figuring out every day i'm
trying to learn what it is to parent but
the part about my dad one of the best
things my dad did is the phone i went to
my dad when they said dad i'm 49
thousand dollars in debt i need you to
bail me out okay
i said you're my father you love me
you're my hero i need you to bail me out
he sat there and he said you're going to
learn the best lesson for me today buddy
i said what's that
i'm not going to bail you out
i said but i'm your son i'm not going to
bail you out
i know you can figure out a way to get
out of this i think you're going to pull
it off this is a man who's a 99-cent
store cashier
who dropped out of school in eighth
grade his son almost followed in his
footsteps but i took four more years
okay but he dropped out in eighth grade
just to start working regular guy okay
for one week i don't talk to my dad
i go around telling everybody [ __ ] you
know your dad this and your dad this and
your dad does it you know my dad bailed
me out i can't believe you're that
dinner and i'm just bitching about my
dad
you know what i did i came back and i
said i'm gonna pay this freaking money
off and i did okay
eventually paid it off my credit went
from 484 495 499 two nice credit score
right
but my dad was not afraid of his son
failing
now if i would have failed if i would
have failed could i have gone and
retaliated against him and started doing
drugs and doing stupid [ __ ] to hurt him
of course
that's the risk a parent has to take
and that's the risk a nation has to take
some of these companies may go out of
business and it may hurt for a year or
two but we got to go through it we got
to stick through it and go through it
and i don't think
politicians
are allowing that to happen
because the people that are supporting
their campaigns
protect them and own them
and that's what i don't like about
american politics
the lobbyist who paul manafort sat in
your chair just two and a half months
ago
there are so many of them out there that
have bought these politicians and it's
screwing up low and middle income
families unfortunately i have to say
it's so spiritual what you're saying
like our whole religion is based on the
same principle which is that like
you know if you don't if you can't if
you don't have the option of failure if
you don't have the option of sin then
you also don't have the option of
redemption and nothing means anything
and and i think that is actually a value
that the american working class is
deeply attached to which is the idea of
autonomy like i want the fruits of my
labor i don't want to hand out i don't i
want the right to fail because without
the right to fail you don't have the
right to succeed i mean that's that's
can i just read the quick definition of
quantitative easing just to kind of
build your case a little bit just and
i'm gonna process how i see and you tell
me if i'm understanding this correctly
so qe quantitative easing is a monetary
policy strategy used by central banks
like the fed
with qe central bank purchases
securities this is this is half of it
purchases securities in an attempt to
reduce interest rates
increase the supply of money
and drive more and here's the keyword
and drive more lending
to consumers and businesses like pat
said oh your credit card's five uh your
credit card limit is five let's bump it
up to 15. so this is kind of the
inflation thing is they just increase
the credit limit increase the lending
what's lending it's just taking on more
debt yeah you're boring hey take on more
debt right but you're not making any
more money yeah you'll figure it out
just take borrow more money but i'm not
my my business actually isn't profitable
that will bail you out we'll keep you
afloat and that's essentially what
you're saying is they're just increasing
the credit limit spend spend spends on
spending but it doesn't seem
like there's
justification based on your income
that's how i'm processing what you're
saying with the increasing the credit
limit yeah yeah listen
failing sucks
it's emotional it's painful it's
embarrassing it's publicly humiliating
uh you know in hollywood you know how
many like i saw a movie the other day
with nicholas cage a new movie that came
out you know what the movie is about
it's about the character in the movie
called nick cage
he's the greatest actor in the world oh
god who no longer is that
needed
i think it's worth watching
but the whole story is about him wow
like it's a movie he's acting himself
but it's like
when they no longer want you to be in a
movie yeah do you know how hard that is
as an actor where you go from being
nicholas freaking cage to nick cage yeah
hey what's up nick
no [ __ ] this guy
he want to oscar he's a freaking
but the point is like
how hard is it when you do one bad movie
it flops in him boom
water world remember waterworld with
kevin or [ __ ] i mean they got a nice
bark in universal studios but that's
pretty much it and
just to piggyback because i mean like
you're amazed especially like with pat
who was such a such an amazing guy not
kissing ask for about this listen to
this so i was in hollywood i was in the
military i was in the air force thank
you so much
my sisters are retiring of 25 years on
friday my brother was in for six years
you know went to there i know that god
put me here to make people laugh that's
my number one i know that's what it says
so fail hollywood i've been on deaf
comedy jam i had a special one kevin
hart called the next level which i think
i have grounds to sue because it's
called the next level and nothing
happened but anyway so i got me and pat
connected to you know instagram and now
i'm here and then just just off what you
were saying last week pat you had like a
php thing at the other office so he had
like what 30 40 people i walk in because
we want to show the sketch that we did
on the video and i'm hanging out pat's
up there he's sitting on the table he's
doing a speech where
you were comparing greed and fear and he
made a chart with so much [ __ ] on it i
almost had a heart attack
but i just sat there and listened to him
for 20 minutes i almost quit comedy and
sat down and started selling [ __ ] no
i can't do that i almost started selling
insurance because i mean it was it was
like and again reading and getting all
that knowledge you fed your brain so
much it's like you could talk about
anything and and it's like a lesson
learned can i just one metaphor that i
think everyone will understand here
because we all know who the person will
talk about is but it's the freedom to
fail we all know the story of michael
jordan in 10th grade he tried out for
the varsity basketball team and what
happened he got cut
yeah so do you use your what yeah you
don't know the story about my dream
i don't know anything about sports jesus
christ
michael jordan the greatest basketball
player potentially the greatest athlete
of all time the story goes in uh
wilmington north carolina he tries out
for the basketball team 10th grade
gets cut
okay
wow so again with the freedom to fail
and he's very good right yeah my journey
turned out to be pretty okay i don't
know how to check his results the
greatest hockey players of all time
more goals than anybody you miss a
hundred percent of the shots you don't
take exactly
um
but
to use the analogy or metaphor i mean
you're the journalist here i don't know
if it's analogy a metaphor either way
um he had to go and improve
so rather than make excuses oh the coach
didn't like me or the parent comes and
talks to the coach hey do my kid like
you know uh
everyone wants a medal these days when
it's a trophy uh culture whatever it is
that these kids have these days
um he had to go get better okay and it
turned out pretty well for the guy okay
but the freedom the freedom to fail
is what inspired him to actually make
the team the following year yes however
is there not a deep tension between what
you guys are saying on the one hand
about freedom to fail
taking responsibility you have the power
you have the ability
and on the other hand
this
quantitative easing
where
if you're really really rich
the government's going to come in and
protect you
like on the one hand yeah i see how it's
consistent with what you're saying on
the other hand to a little guy who he
doesn't get bailed out when he defaults
on his credit card he doesn't get bailed
out when he can't pay his loans he gets
his house taken away and i think that
that is something that you know
elizabeth warren and donald trump
totally were in agreement about and
totally correct which is that there is a
level at which it is rigged on behalf of
the people who have already made on
behalf of the rich you're not gonna go
to jail for white collar crime because
it costs too much to prosecute it you
know but if you jump the turnstile you
know you're going i mean obviously now
progressives don't think you should go
away yeah exactly you can kill people
and get away with it now but you know
that there's a level at which this idea
of accountability um adheres like a
gazillion percent if you're in the
bottom and like zero percent if you're
at that i agree i actually agree with
you and i don't appreciate that
i don't appreciate that i don't
appreciate when politicians get in there
and the guys at the top can buy them and
you prevent them from going out of
business let them fail
let them fail a great philosopher once
said let the boy watch
he needs to say let them fail i don't
know that reference but i bet it's
hilarious do you know that philosophy
i've heard about it
let the boy watch will ferrell
the billionaires failed yeah will
ferrell needs to say well let's see i
don't know if you agree with chamath you
know who chemotherapy is the tech guy
silicon valley golden state warriors
the first time that i heard somebody say
[ __ ] them let them fail was during covid
when they bailed out the airline
businesses do you remember all this yeah
and
it was like people oh what huh he's
coming on and saying this i mean he's
kind of you know his whole spax
situation going on people you know agree
with him disagree with him but he
basically was like [ __ ] him let him fail
and and and people on uh cnbc uh their
minds are all over the champions or was
that article right there u.s shouldn't
bail out hedge funds billionaires during
covet uh during coveted pandas hedge
funds but there's ones first yeah
there's also airlines but he was like
[ __ ] him let him fail
and people on
financial media cnbc bloomberg were like
brain splattered on the wall what do you
mean let him fail
he's like yeah let him fail it's
essentially what pat's saying stop
bailing the big boys out
yeah because if you get in the arena
like can you imagine like imagining ufc
is like
no you can't hit that hard yeah
oh no
you know
ali's been the best for a long time we
have to protect him give him those
points no bro he lost that's if if the
greatest of all time fails in front of
millions of people and everybody writes
about it let these guys fail a little
bit as well okay okay if they don't make
it bad no problem if you do you do did
you see this one bitcoin company it's
called celsius right i don't know and if
you guys saw this or not this company
celsius got a valuation of 25 billion
dollars do you know what's happened to
them during the last six months in
valuation they went from 25 billion
dollars
267 million dollars
this guy went from buying the yankees
to now he's
being called on the board that he can't
buy nothing he went from being able to
go to a restaurant nobu and says this
sushi's awesome i'm buying this place
for 15 million bucks yeah that 25
billion is down to 167.
guess what this means guess what the
market is saying it's okay
that's that's what you did you somehow
someway screwed up you lost this happens
to everyone you make a bad investment
and
the business goes under you thought it
was going to do good let them fail so
anyways i think we've talked touched on
this failed topic plenty of times
we're right so do you mind taking a
moment
i would want to know
some of your like the areas of you say
you're a marxist specifically what part
of marxist do you agree with because
you'll agree with me about all of them i
think yeah okay and
i'm curious i'm really curious i'm
really happy you went here yeah but um i
also i really want to hear about your
parents um getting divorced and then
remarried and then divorced and was that
about ideology like about the
imperialism
you know what's crazy you know it's
crazy
my sister's christian my uh
brother-in-law he's a baha'i he was a
baha'i and now he's a christian what are
you are you religious i'm a christian
myself yeah but
he was a baha'i
she was a christian they got married
politically they're on the same page
they're happily married celebrating i
think 19 or 20 years of marriage of
where they're at right now they've got
two beautiful kids grace and sean love
these guys my mom and dad
they're both christians okay okay so
religious on the same page politically
complete opposite page
world war iii would have gotten started
because of these two guys they should
have never gotten married because
politically
they're on opposite this is why i
respect kellyanne conway and george
comey yeah
let me tell you man shout out to my
parents couldn't do it they they pulled
up figured out a way to do it yes we'll
see time will tell if they stay together
it's it's uh yeah that's kind of what
happened for them they should they
should have gotten married i'm kind of
glad they did and i'm kind of glad they
got married the second time around
because that's why i'm here
you were in the second time i was like
let's try to make it work let's make a
baby then comes patrick not like this
didn't work let's get a divorce so
that's see patches that's a great
example of failure they came back and
now it's you
you find them to fail
to fail pat is here because
this is why we pay vinnie the big deal
that's right you gotta bring it all guys
is that an example like they failed they
said you know what we're going to try
again they made this freaking amazing
guy and now that's it we're over here
listen
please
you know if
if if the social media was around when i
was sinning you wouldn't say this great
guy because when social media was around
i was a professional
you know until today but at that time it
was like trying to compete as the
ultimate 20 some years ago yeah uh thank
god for all the silicon valley folks to
not have invented you know snapchat
instagram back and we're gonna take it
down
i'm so grateful for that totally yeah so
go ahead so tell us oh yeah yeah marxism
okay let me start with the things i
don't agree with okay i don't think that
work is like inherently oppression you
know he really thought that it was like
that labor was oppression
um i don't think that i think there's
dignity in labor and i don't think you
can get self-esteem from something
somebody gives you like you can only get
it by working for it and so i totally
don't disagree with mark's on that i
disagree that the only thing between
people is power he was sort of like he
got that from hegel but like that idea
that like we should replace a world view
based on right versus wrong with the
worldview based on who has power and who
doesn't or that anybody who employs
someone is you know in a relationship
that's oppressive i don't believe in any
of that you know obviously i don't
believe in what he thought about
religion i think that religion's really
really important um to a function
how do you mean by religion what was his
view on religion you're saying karl marx
let him go through it yeah
like he was like a materialistic you
know he was materialism yeah yeah i
don't believe any of that and an atheist
type of deal um and and i'm very against
like critical race theory which is they
took the marxist um you know it was
really a hegelian binary and they
applied it to race and said okay
that power binary right that marx
thought was like between like the
bourgeoisie the boss and then the
laborer right where the only thing
between those two was a power imbalance
and oppression in critical race theory
they say you have white people and
people of color and it's that same thing
right like people white people have all
the power and their only relationship
with people of color is oppressive i
think that's all disgusting and terrible
and gross and wrong and what the worst
people to ever walk planet earth
believed so i'm i don't believe any of
that but i would like to say that like
the problem with critical race theory is
the insufficiency of marxism
not that it's marxist because what i
mean by that is to me what marx got
right i don't know if it was true for
his moment but in our moment right now
fundamentally the divide in america is
not about politics and it's not about
race it's about class we have a huge
class divide in america that separates
the college educated you know from the
working class like that that is the
fundamental reality of american life if
you have a college degree you will make
on average a million dollars more over
the course of your lifetime than if you
don't you will have better health you
will live longer and your children will
be upwardly mobile you will have access
to the american dream and if you don't
increasingly you won't increasingly you
will die sooner your body will break
down earlier you'll face deaths of
despair i mean it's bad right and you
will not have access to the american
dream increasingly you won't be able to
buy a home you won't be able to access
that next level so that divide like i'm
seeing that through a clock that's
seeing it through a class analysis using
the lens of class to understand the real
struggles in america that to me is
marxist but the reason i say i think you
would agree with me is i noticed
something during covet which was that
the the people who opposed the lockdowns
they were doing it
because
yes there was the freedom thing yes but
that wasn't the thing that motivated the
emotional response on the right
to these authoritarian lockdowns what
motivated the emotional response was
what motivated me which was the disgust
with allowing yourself because of your
financial security to rise so far above
the people you relied on to survive
meaning we're gonna enforce a lockdown
because we can work from home right so
we're gonna keep making our money and
protect ourselves from the plague but
we're gonna force you to go out into the
plague and stock those shelves and bring
those packages and bring us that food
and we're going to then tell you how to
live your life so we're going to make
there's going to be nothing out there
for you to do except labor for us right
except deliver our packages right
nothing's going to be open for you
you're going to have to brave the plague
and go out into the danger so we can
protect ourselves and then they
misunderstood
what was essentially their economic
privilege right of being able to work
from home as virtue they thought they
were more virtuous because they were
staying home
right so they they took this thing that
was a class divide where they really
were in such a better situation than the
people who they relied on to work and
keep them alive and then they wanted to
keep that
they they they made that distinction
even bigger and bigger and bigger and
kept pushing for policy to make that
distinction even greater and greater and
greater and what i saw on the right was
a marxist disgust with with with the
bourgeoisie with these educated elites
for um creating a situation that
benefited them suddenly their houses
were worth so much more right um but
then and then oh and then the kicker was
as soon as they had a vaccine they were
like oh now you have to take it or you
get fired right like it was so
disgusting and i think that that disgust
is mark's i would call that marxist in
nature it is a disgust with a class
divide that one side is sitting there
benefiting from and then stewing in its
own sort of moral like virtue
while oppressing other people like that
that's a marxist analysis of covet and i
i bet you would agree with my analysis
did you read karl marx's book or carlito
none of that is
yeah so let me sign up whatever she is
they're like
this is the
man carl's cousin or brother that we
forgot about carlito
you got to give her some credit though
that's amazing because the remote
the the college educated remote worker
lifestyle wfh work from anywhere work
from home i'm living in uh tulum now i'm
moving to miami uh hey just but but i
gotta that's something that that's uh
that what she's saying is very accurate
versus hey go deliver my groceries go to
the door dash i don't think that's smart
that has nothing to do with marxism okay
by five
that's not marxism what would you call
it that's that's not a lot of those are
libertarian philosophies that you have
you know where leave people alone and
stop forcing [ __ ] down my like
let me live my life and get the hell out
of my way and stop thinking you're so
much more special than me because you
got a degree and i don't that's not
marxism a part of marx
was
he felt there was people that were
better to be put in charge to lead
others
rather than you know he was the one that
thought most of the people were dumb
that's that's marx's idea was more from
the standpoint of there is us who are
more educated than you and we know
what's right for you to live and you
don't believe in that that's not your
approach so a lot of the marxist
you know i've interviewed probably more
communist on a youtube channel than
anybody has done on youtube i like
talking to communists because you know
it's a great conversation to have but
but let me let me give you an idea about
what i noticed during covet yeah you
almost won the worst thing that happened
to kovit
which political party you think
lost
uh during covet
well so i something that i'd like to say
is
i'm going to get cancelled for saying
this but um
i am going to get cancer saying this but
i i think for a long time reality had a
liberal bias like it was the liberals
who were pushing equality for blacks it
was the liberals who were pushing
equality for gays things that we all now
agree are like commonsensical right like
that every human deserves to live in
dignity but i think
over the last five years
last three years the last two years and
certainly over covet with the school
lockdowns with the endless lockdowns
with the you know this oppression of the
working class i really think that
reality has sort of started to take on a
bit of a conservative bias like it does
seem to me that the right
increasingly on questions that matter
very much to the american people
like the right to have a say over their
children's education their children's
life their right to bodily autonomy you
know their right to live in dignity
their right to the american dream a lot
of these things i think increasingly you
hear conservatives speaking to where
most americans are at and representing a
reality that the left has really sort of
left in the dust
i agree i agree that it's and by the way
some of the folks that maybe are
listening to you that are more
your side politically are kind of
sitting there saying well you can't say
that because if we do you know
didn't you just see the stat that a
million people switch from democrat to
republican the story just came out two
weeks ago you're helping that even more
but i would say this the political party
that lost the rinkovic they initially
won it's kind of like a basketball game
when they came and said you know the
celtics are up 28 points in the first
quarter
the celtics lost by 17 points to the
golden state warriors so the democrats
started off with a big lead in the first
half oh my god look at you
freaking republicans and then fourth
quarter came around
what the hell were these guys doing
it it unfortunately unfortunately a part
of covet was awesome for america to see
i'm not talking the loss of loved ones
any of that
i'm talking a part of kovit was it
revealed what the motive really was for
the people on the left big time it
revealed and what do you think that
motive was control i know what's right
for you
you know last night shout out to elena
who works here uh
do you know where the concept of
buildback better came out of
the world economic forum yeah so the
world economic forum is the original
build back better if you ever do you
have the link to this of i'm going to
show this it's our friend klaus schwab
that was a scary joke yeah so i'm going
to send this to you i want you to pull
this up and and uh just take a look at
this article on a world economic forum
and and look at what the date is okay
that's what's concerning when was a when
was the election by the way when was the
election november of of what year okay
so so i want you to look at this article
tyler pull this article up that i just
sent you
pull this article up and look at the
date it's kind of weird
i'm not i'm not uh i think if you're
watching this folks i think you need to
dig into this for your own self and do a
little bit of research spend 30 minutes
on this and play around and see what you
figure out and pat the world for is it
just a bunch of people rich elites that
are just gathering talking about what
what's good for us and what's not good
for us i know some of them we're talking
about how you shouldn't own
your new world order that's what you
wanted to become okay so watch this what
is the date
uh july maybe a little bit smaller so
they see the logo at the top and they
know what the link is what's the logo at
the top if you can zoom in world
economics can they see it right there
zoom in a little bit on the logo all the
way at the top of the website it says
world economic forum if you look at the
link it's the world economic forum
website.org
look at the date
july 13 2020. oh my god i feel like i
need a tinfoil hat
in this back better we must reinvent
capitalism
and then
biden without even
holding anything back
comes and they call it the build back
back better
the pandemic has brought us the focus of
vulnerabilities in our systems and
institutions but it also offers us a
chance to shape a more resilient and
sustainable world here's how businesses
and policy makers can start building the
green and inclusive
future we need thanks to an ongoing
pandemic thanks to the ongoing planet
the world is off balance and over money
so far for years to come
far from settling into a new normal we
should expect the kova 19 domino effect
triggering further disruptions positive
as well as negative over the decade
ahead
okay so if you keep going lower and
lower there's a part that they talk
about a few different things okay go
lord that's the part so right there the
world's largest shipping company is
setting up a research center to
decarbonize the industry the great reset
after kova 19 must put people first
four-way stakeholder capitalism can
create a more resilient post-covet mana
region
so i don't know you know like you think
about it from this standpoint imagine if
you know if uh 30 years from now
a person goes up and goes runs for
office
and their campaign is called make
america great again
30 years from now yeah okay i'm gonna be
73. what's the first thing we're going
to be thinking about you guys like that
you stole that what heard it already
make america great again was from a guy
named trump you know what the
billionaire yeah you guys weren't with
that guy yeah make america great again
so imagine if you take a campaign
from somebody in germany on what his
campaign was and it's the identical
you're not even changing a little bit
grow back better you know
like
ver
bettum
we need to build back better to reset
a true recovery from copenhagen will not
be about putting things back together
the way they were we need to build back
better to reset
this is why so many people are writing a
book called the great
reset i think beck wrote a book i think
a couple other people just wrote a book
this is their model it's a great reset
you'll own nothing and be happy yeah and
that's what it was so so i don't know so
for me during covet what it did is we
really figured out what your motives
were like okay cool that's what your
motive is no problem
the moment i know and you know someone's
motive like when a woman goes on a date
with a guy and he's straight up says
look just out of an ugly divorce
i have no desire to have a girlfriend
but if you want to have fun let's go to
my place have fun i'll come to your
place if you just want to have fun
so
guess what advantage you have now
now you know my what
motive
so you can decide what to do with that
motive so now you have to make a
decision that's what
you either are going to say
between us
let's go chill
i'm cool
okay
or you may say
yeah
i've actually been out of a relationship
for a couple years and it was a bad one
but i'm ready to get into a relationship
and i actually want somebody that i can
have a serious relationship with i've
had too many of these tinder stuff the
last couple years i'm done i kind of
want to have somebody serious
now i know your motive our motives don't
match but you know mine and i know yours
great
the democrat the democrats uh some of
them on the left kept their motives now
we know their motives and it's a
beautiful thing
because it's very hard to go back this
is why a lot of people who were
democrats who were registered democrats
saying i'm sorry bro i'm not with that
dog
i'm i'm okay you're there i'm not with
you
you can't log on to instagram for
whatever reason it doesn't allow us
just go to worldstar
i'd love to see the demographics i
follow world star like sometimes the
challenge
challenge about following the world
style when you're married is sometimes
i'm going through instagram somebody's
name some girls naked doing twerking my
mom's like what do you want i'm like
babe i just follow a word don't blame me
if you go on world star
a story came out uh they posted a
picture recently i wish i can just show
this to you oh here it is
uh they posted this okay what is it is
it the potus tweet yeah the poker tweet
can you just put this up and and i love
the question they posed okay on
worldstar
very simple
they posed the question first of all
they put the tweet from the president
can zoom in
gas prices have been dropping for 34
straight days about 50 cents a gallon
that saves the average driver about 25 a
month i know those extra dollars and
cents means something it's breathing
room and we're not done working to get
prices even lower okay
he tweets this worldstar puts it up and
look what they put
are the gas prices going down in your
city
i dare you to go down all the comments
people left and find one that supports
what president biden where are they
dropping though
no no i you just have to see it's comedy
if you watch what people are saying
you're full of [ __ ] i'm so sick of it
people are not holding back so a lot of
people are sitting there saying dude by
the way you know what a lot of them were
saying we need trump back yeah we need
trump back this is not like a
breitbart website no this is not uh
turning point usa no this is world star
daily this is world star world star yeah
okay this is world star so
kovit revealed a lot and those people
who are not lazy who are willing to
think for themselves are sitting there
saying
listen man this ain't working out okay
at the top of my priority is for me to
have the my economy be okay my personal
life so i can take care of my wife my
husband my kids my family and i'm i
can't do it right now this [ __ ] is too
much and they're getting sick of the
game so i think kovid was very good to
reveal motives of both political parties
and people learned a lot look what
happened to bill maher bill maher blew
up yeah okay
sounds like he was
bill maher sounds like a conservative
like he would vote for trump i know i'm
joking but he sounds completely
everything that he was preaching two
years ago he's completely flip he
doesn't he doesn't like anything i want
to read the super chat real quick
because it's about you it's from dl
saint i really want to know podcast 20
bucks vinnie is one of the funniest
comics in the game he's put into work
the true g keep doing you vinnie i love
it that's a shout out for you
we have another one here andrew hugh who
said world economic forum event 230 was
kova 19 role play the wf are behind it
all and biden macron trudeau johnson and
all leaders who are controlled by the wf
look at the w agenda 2030 and esg scores
you may want to go do research for
yourself i'm not going to get into it
but i suggest you may want to look into
scott rodriguez this is for vinnie
hahaha anyways okay people are loving
vineyards
not to cut you off so and i was watching
so you took notes like a professional
like pat you ever know to adam this uh
stay in school and read books look at my
this is my
quantitative easing
the turkey with the hand and then that's
me and i'm just not
so the opposable thumb very impressive
you guys don't mind if we spend the last
40 minutes going into some issues and
getting some thoughts on issues let's do
it let's go into some of these issues
here okay
so uh papa papa uh let's go through new
york times uh july 11. so this is a this
is a recent story most democrats don't
want biden in 2024 new poll shows okay
uh
president obama is facing an alarming
level of doubt from uh inside his own
party with 64 percent of democratic
voters saying they would prefer a new
standard bearer in the 2024 presidential
campaign according to new york times
siena college poll as voters nationwide
have soared soured on his leadership
giving him a meager 33 percent job
approval rating widespread concerns
about the economy and inflation have
helped turn the national mood
decidedly
dark both on mr biden and the trajectory
of the nation more than three quarters
of registered voters see the united
states moving in the wrong direction a
pervasive sense of pessimism that spans
every corner of the country every age
range and racial group city suburbs and
rural rural areas as well as both
political parties only 13 american
voters said the nation was on the right
track the lowest point in times polling
since the depth of the financial crisis
more than a decade ago what do you think
about this when you hear the story from
new york times
well i mean
sometimes they actually get the story
right the new york times you might
disagree with that but
the the number one thing that
republicans well the democrats should be
hoping for
in 2024 is that trump runs
because the only way the democrats can
still win in 2024 is if it's trump you
might be saying what the hell are you
talking about right now
because if a desantis runs or someone
with
mass appeal it's a cakewalk
but if trump gets back in there and
starts mudslinging again
i don't think
the people on the right fully understand
you might have a good grasp of this
just how much even if it's against their
own pocketbook and against their own
interests
how nails on a chalkboard he is to their
ears
again it might be counterintuitive while
he was better for us
trump gets on screen gets on tv and
democrats have a meltdown i'm willing to
bet that at one point you had trump
derangement syndrome did you not i did
yeah okay
and half of america did pretty bad
though i mean we had to let
luckily they were very gorgeous women
and things are okay now i'm a little
more reasonable
but you fully understand just how much
people on the left
really
really
can't stomach
trump it's a guttural
nails on a chalkboard when he gets
america and people just like i like
you understand fully
so for me
i'm telling
putting this out there i've never voted
for a republican for president in my
life i will gladly take a ron desantis
or someone who has those um conservative
agendas just because i think democrat i
had a conversation with a very high up
democratic uh
fundraiser here in on the dnc side one
of my best friends i was like you
understand how
[ __ ] up the democrats are doing these
days he's like yeah i'm totally with you
and i said the democrats are praying
that trump is the is the
candidate in uh 2024 stop 100 stop
because the sentence is like the santos
you really believe that [ __ ] ten
thousand percent you really believe that
yeah really okay so let me ask you
because you can stomach trump so you
don't understand what i'm saying because
i can set aside my emotions home and
you're one of two percent of the people
that can do that don't need everybody
and more of america needs to learn to be
like her and sit down and have she had
trump derangement syndrome but she's
getting over it
but how many other people have gotten
over it but no no but by the way a lot
of people have gone over it a lot of
people have gone over yeah but you
selective hearing want to believe that
let me explain to you something for you
to be thinking about okay
let's let's take your argument of
they want uh trump to run oh really yeah
if they really wanted trump to run you
wouldn't see [ __ ] with january 6 hearing
zero if they really wanted trump to run
you wouldn't see an article coming out
saying iran is trying to assassinate
president trump oh my god because the
democrats want him to run if democrats
wanted trump to run they would sit down
nancy pelosi with guys enough will
generally let this guy run he's going to
lose let this guy run he's going to lose
do you see republicans worried about
hillary clinton running republicans are
hoping
hillary clinton running they're not even
getting in or wait have you heard
republicans talking [ __ ] about hillary
because they're hoping that's how you
know any time they go after somebody
they're afraid that guy's gonna run and
you're smart enough and wise enough to
know the difference but selective
hearing no gets you to say well now
because the democrats are hoping he runs
no i'm not you're not you're taking half
of my argument no no you have to know
better than that i'm saying do they want
trump yeah hell no do they are they
rooting for trump hell no but they're
saying they're looking at the field
they're saying
if biden is the guy which i don't think
he will be
who do we have a better chance against
young
uh vibrant rhonda sanchez to be wiser
than that strategically
you just made you don't think that john
desantis has a better chance of beating
a democrat than trump i think ron
burgundy has a better chance of beating
anybody on the left right now it doesn't
matter who it is i the point i'm trying
to make to you is just think about the
logic of what you're saying right now
okay you know the saying is son too says
if an enemy is falling don't get in his
way get out of his way let him fall okay
that's strategic no problem
if they're really afraid of trump
falling
why do they keep getting in his way
they're afraid
they're afraid of this guy whether it's
true or not it's here i don't think
trump's a strategy going after musk and
doing all that i don't i don't
you know you heard what i said on the
guy you know a couple people on twitter
came after me saying what happened to
you you had our back and you were trump
i said i've never been
a trump an anti-trump a pro this i've
been a economy guy with policies that
allows us to be left alone and the same
people that were so ecstatic about this
guy was going to become a president to
unify america is the reason why we're
experiencing what we're experiencing
right now so i understand the idea of
protecting your vote because it sucks
when you lose
i understand it to have to protect that
i still made the right decision because
i would have never would have i get it
the ego is a hard thing we all have it
totally understand that but the premise
behind the fact that oh dude democrats
are hoping for
get over at that point
i'm just my last gun god pat
and i want to get your opinion here we
go respectfully
i'm not saying i don't think you
understand
i generally don't
how disgusted i understand strategy no
no no hear me out
how disgusted half of america feels when
they see him speak i don't think you
fully get i run an insurance company
with 27 000 agents in 49 states who talk
to these people every day i don't think
you understand that i'm around these
guys constantly from every state and
you're only in florida i'm in every
state okay i'm not but what i'm trying
to tell you is i hear their last week
we're doing something at the office and
i said hillary clinton is a sweetheart
one of the ladies said she is a
sweetheart
i'm in the street talking i know i'm
i have to be there i have to win the
guy's vote or else you don't go you
don't have a business
that you're growing
america's bigger than new york city
america's bigger than miami okay america
is america you got 50 states you're
dealing with and a lot of them
it doesn't need to be a hundred percent
of them it just needs to be five to ten
percent of them disagree with you 10 000
people in the midwest that's who
controls our country that's the point
yeah and they're sick of it not not adam
by the way
you whether you're going to work i don't
know
do do what you got to do a lot of people
are very protective of who they voted
because they hate being wrong
it's zero percent about me i'm talking
about fifty percent of the country that
when trump speaks yeah it's nails on a
chalkboard to them who gives a [ __ ]
because because when joe biden speaks
it's freaking awesome no they go to
sleep because when he speaks they go to
sleep
i
arrangement syndrome you know exactly
what i'm talking about yeah but but
not that just a really fast to defend
not sorry to cut you off but uh i think
the reason that pat they're doing the
january 6 talking to do just so that if
he does they can just say threat to
democracy they can use those boxes
because and i'm i'm kind of i'm kind of
with adam in the sense that
a question to you guys all do you think
the desantis
would win over trump if they both find
if they're both running that's a
different conversation but i'm saying
who would because the left is gonna have
a field day with threats of democracy
they're gonna still talk about russia
they're gonna bring in all the other old
[ __ ] that they're gonna jam it on there
they have nothing to really about your
energy the right strategy if you're not
intimidated of somebody and you want
that person to run
get the hell out of their way yep that's
strategy
okay get out of there let them keep
talking [ __ ] about you you know how many
times have you heard me on camera talk
[ __ ] about former colleagues or people
that we do business with how many times
have you heard zero
because it's not my style i don't do it
even if they do and they do it all the
time you don't see me getting up there
it's not my style okay because the
market then gets to decide
listen you know the only story however
the others that pat doesn't get up and
takes all the [ __ ] no problem because
eventually the market's gonna sit there
and say
damn okay i didn't know that no problem
yeah get the hell out of the way let the
market decide because you're not worried
about it they're so worried about trump
i agree if you're not let them lose
please i want to hear your thoughts yeah
please well i was gonna ask you who if
you could like if who would you like to
see running in 2024 on both sides and
each party like who would you pick if
you could pick not trump and not biden i
think it's time for a friend i would
take a desantis uh-huh and whoever the
left kind of plucks out of thin air yeah
who would you i mean
i've been saying this for five [ __ ]
years joe manchin is america he ain't
running totally he's definitely i've
been saying like who told you about joe
manchin three years ago how many times i
have to give you exactly okay thank you
i'm saying like any democrat i'm a
person no matter what if you watch the
show that i do on this side of the room
i'm the type of person who sits down
with this type of person with this
type of philosophy and an exact type of
different type of philosophy i say guys
let's figure something out let's see how
we could all work together because more
than a republican or democrat i'm an
american
i like i travel the world i don't like
going around the world and being like ah
you know stupid american i'm like i'm a
[ __ ] american we up in this thing
yeah i like when america has a good
stature in the world and that you can be
proud to be an american and over the
last whether it's biden or trump it's
not exactly america's got a good
reputation throughout the world so i
would love to have someone whoever it is
that has a 60 approval rating in america
and it's not fine and it's not trump i'm
sorry
so there you go it's very interesting
how about yourself
well i mean i think the debate you guys
are having is so fascinating something
i've noticed is that um which it's kind
of could be support for either side
democrats who don't understand
um the extent to which republicans right
now are ambivalent about trump
especially with the specter of desantis
rising
they in their mind because they have
created out of trump this kind of
bogeyman who's so all-encompassing they
cannot see the polling that's showing
that desantis is already neck and neck
with him and they haven't even declared
and i know a lot of democrats who would
vote for desantis i think he has about
60 approval here in the state and this
is my entire point so everything we've
been talking about yeah so but i so i
think that the democrats are have a real
blindness when it comes to what's
happening on the republican side so you
know i think actually maybe that does
support pat's point a little bit
that um they don't think they can run
against him i think they're doing
january 6 because they are convinced he
would beat biden and um i think they're
wrong about that not i mean actually i
don't i don't think i agree with you
buying is not i don't think biden's
gonna run but um you know i i cannot see
how with these numbers desantis doesn't
blow trump out of the water and i think
to the extent that you know trump
doesn't like to lose it's possible he
doesn't even run if desantis can get you
know up you know past i don't know 35 40
50 right and people are you know trump's
down in the 30s
i just think that it's um i'm shocked to
see him not surprised but um it is
astounding to see how how are the
numbers you're quoting like there's a
difference in a republican primary and a
national electorate right well so now it
republican
as a much better broad
appeal to americans
then
um
then trump does but i don't know what
the republican base looks like okay
in polls of republican primary voters
they're now neck and neck
and no and no one's declared i mean the
idea that desantis has a such a national
profile to compete with a former
president it's crazy it's crazy and i
think it speaks volumes to how he's
governed which is why do you think
republicans feel that way about desantis
when they've been so all about trump for
the past five years i do think this
january six hearings have hurt him i i
do think that and i think more than that
he's hurt himself you know
trump if you really watch i agree with
him if you watched his speeches you
watched his
rallies
in 2016 in 2020 he talked over and over
and over again about nafta about jobs
about the economy and of course yeah
he'd throw in you know the red meat for
the press actually some you know
quasi-racist comments so that they'd
make sure that the press would cover
because they would only cover it if he
did that right but he was talking about
the economy and jobs he was saying to
the working class they have stolen
everything from you
now since 2020 all he talks about is
himself they've stolen everything from
me
that is the difference and that's very
very unattractive okay totally it's very
unattractive and somebody behind closed
doors
has to give them the feedback to realize
people don't like that approach okay
let people tell you
let other people say you're doing a
great job
you shouldn't constantly brag about you
every once in a while it's okay to be
self-promotion shameless all that stuff
leave me there's a lot of guys on
instagram and twitter that tick tock
that are blowing up because they're
great at shameless self-promotion fine
it's a little bit of that is necessary
we know who some of these guys are
but he's at a point right now that he
may be losing certain people as well
my argument wasn't about
that you're wrong my argument is the
fact that
your premise of democrats are hoping for
him to run is wrong they're not hoping
for him to run in because if they did
they wouldn't have done what they're
doing i know can i just qualify with my
showing yeah they're hoping that it's
him as the candidate or dissent over
desantis okay because
of yeah what are they gonna say about
the sanctions nothing okay he doesn't
like saying the word gay check this out
okay this is from vegas so much ammo
against trump this is vegas insider.com
2024 election betting gods trump's at
the top
plus 275.
dennis desantis guys
that is
very close
very close yeah biden 550 i cannot
believe kamala is fourteen honestly i
can't believe she's fourteen
i don't think she stands a chance zero
uh pence then buddhich then haley then
michelle obama then warren then tucker
and the rest of the folks
by the way in that i just want to get
your opinion because i i'll give you my
answer in that what is the most
interesting storyline
oh that's michelle
i do just want to say one
one thing on the on the previous point
um it to me it is tragic what trump is
doing now because his legacy is so
strong i think even somebody on the left
can say like the things he did for the
country before the pandemic there was so
much there to run on to brag about and
and he's just he squandered the whole
thing over this this nonsense and i i i
find that to be a little bit tragic um
you're giving me side eye because you're
like what are you do for those corners
no i'm not saying that they're saying
there's a you have to be very careful in
life
okay
very careful i've had a lot of enemies
over the years
i had a
lunch a few weeks ago with one of my
biggest enemies in business okay
and we had lunch and we sat down it was
an incredible lunch we had together okay
fast to the point where the at the end
the hug was like a brotherly hug and
listen wow we wanted to kill each other
okay this is one of your enemies you're
saying yeah you don't need to go any
deeper than that because so this is
somebody that's an enemy in business
okay
you have to be very careful to not hate
or be envious
and you have to be able to logically
give credit where credits do even if i'm
not a lebron james fan at
all
i give him tremendous credit what he did
with all the odds being against him to
become who he is today with his as a
father as a leader to his family
tremendous credit i don't agree with
what he's saying even saying to griner
if i was her i don't know if i'd come
back to him yeah all the stuff that he
does i don't support any i think too
much bitching but i support the fact
that he's done what he's done so you got
to be careful because for somebody to
become a billionaire
went on tv and to become a president
namely one person that's done that
including reagan he's never done that so
his legacy he's one of a kind just so
you may he's one he's going to be one of
the most controversial uh most written
about figures in the history of america
but he's one of a kind only one person
ever has become a billionaire one on tv
and become a president only one
person's ever done that not 50
he ain't one in five he's in one of one
okay hate him love them trash them do
whatever you can name me one other
person that's done that you can't do
that so but if you look at this list i
would love
to do a fundraiser at my house i would
do it for number one
i would do for number two
i don't think three and four running i
would do a fundraiser for number six
pete i would do a fundraiser for obama
wait you you do pete but not pence i
pence fine i just don't think pence has
a chance i just don't think pence has a
chance i think pete
could have a chance i think michelle
definitely i don't think uh what's uh is
that warren i i think bernie's too old i
think i would do a fundraiser and bring
people to ask real questions i've been
part of these fundraisers before and
it's not like hey what's up can we take
a picture it's not like hey can i get a
picture to post on instagram no it's
like hey so tell me what do you think
about this stuff why are you doing this
like how do you handle a situation like
i want to be able to ask peter a couple
questions i want to be able to ask
michelle a couple questions you know on
and where she's at because there's a
difference between michelle and barack
and 04 one-term senators who are broke
to michelle and barack obama today who
are worth a few hundred
million dollars there's a different
perspective for business so i'd love to
speak to michelle about that and say hey
let's do a fundraiser ask some questions
and i'll bring some people that are from
both sides of the aisle and we'll raise
whatever the amount is 25 bucks ahead 25
i don't know what their dollar amount is
but i would love to do that to see both
sides of the aisle okay to do that so
for me it's not i'm a trump guy i'm a
desantis guy i'm a you know uh who's
your guy uh a mansion yesterday i
tweeted something about mansion and i
said uh yesterday about mansion uh uh i
said joe manchin
i gotta read this to you because it's so
ironic that you're talking about him
today and this was my tweet yesterday i
said joe manchin someone give joe
manchin a medal of honor okay i think at
the end of the day this guy's gonna get
a lot more credit to have kept america
together during because [ __ ] could be a
lot worse if there was not a mansion
today but that's the answer so but i
think you're the exception and i don't
do this often but i'm going to give
credit to adam here
american politics the presidential race
is very much a popularity contest that's
all it is people don't care about
policies you go ask the average american
what policies of trump they like they
can't give you an answer and what i
think is very interesting here is that
nowhere on this list is gavin newsom i
think it's fairly obvious gavin newsom's
going to be the candidate yeah i think
that's who they want i think that's who
they're going to push i think that's who
they're going to have
people don't like kamala people think
pete's a joke
elizabeth warren is she's i think people
see through her um bernie the party
won't let bernie win i think it's
obvious news is going to be the
candidate donald trump cannot beat gavin
newsom andrew cuomo
you don't think trump can be gathered
absolutely not absolutely not i think
people aren't going to care about what
happened in california i think people
are going to look gavin newsom
purely on his looks and the way he
speaks i do know he was a girl
i don't think people care about people
by the way if you don't think you can
get it i think adam just nailed it no
gavin newsom is the justice yeah yeah
yeah he's the you saw what joe uh joe
just had to say totally
nominated any of these against
trump yeah
i'm telling you and adam's right the
left's biggest fears that ron desantis
runs that is your biggest fight i think
you make a good point with january 6. by
the way scroll up for a little bit
this is the storyline that i wanted you
are right but i don't think the left
realizes it that that's what i think is
somewhere between the two of you you're
right
that you know
they should want trump to win but they
don't realize it because orange man bad
like they can't they're not they can't
they're still deranged so
hard to hate someone for that long and
then be like go back to the first 10
minutes of the podcast by the way
remember you're an exception most people
aren't going to do the research
taking that angle guys
be careful taking that angle because if
you take that angle what you're trying
to say is the american voter is lazy
that's what you're saying i don't know
we just become very careful because if
tyler's saying that's his position
you know the other way all the way to
the top yeah so you're saying the
american voters lazy
we discussed this at the beginning but
by the way you know who is very
interesting because he has he's been
he's just been kind of quiet but he's
going to be there it and he's not scared
is number one two three four
five
1600
that is mike pence oh pence if you see
what's going on he's going after there
are
what is it called uh like what they're
doing uh when you like fight a war but
uh but roxy proxy war wow so right now
they're having a proxy war in the state
of wyoming totally mike pence is
supporting liz cheney yep january 6th uh
insurrection uh committee
and
donald trump is supporting the lady who
kind of looks like a dude in my opinion
she's in the lead the ladies in the lead
and they're fighting these proxy wars
they did the same thing in georgia
where um pence supported
the governor who ended up winning and
and trump supported his ca
trump and pence yeah they got some
serious beef going on big time and pence
was this was a movie there would be like
you know what i mean the confrontation
and pence was the greatest bootlicker of
all time big time he was trump could do
no wrong and then on january 6 when he
almost got hung he hung him out to dry
and now i was on route what's a little
reward i was on reuben podcast a couple
days ago shout out to dave rubin when
you guys go play your uh basketball room
there but i was on his podcast and he
said so you know what would be like a
creative candidate mix i said
desantis ivanka trump would be very
interesting okay desantis as the
president
as the
candidate and ivanka as the vp you know
why
uh because the trump camp
will say at least there is a trump there
and the democrat camp that is not
willing to vote for donald but they're
willing to vote for
ivanka because they're comfortable with
her that's a very creative way of doing
things it's distance enough and close
enough where the democrats who are
saying i will not vote for trump but i
think they'll vote for desantis and
trump it's a creative way now for that
to happen guys i don't think the santas
is going to pick her as a vp i think
desantis is a guy that plays it very
safe yeah yeah scott is for sure
yeah he's going to go with guys
for sure but he'll be a great pick pat
what do you think trump's vp pick would
be if it just happened right now who
would it be i just haven't heard his
name thrown out there that much he asked
the question what do you think trump's
trump's vp pick would be if right now
that happened right can i tell you i
think it's going to be
someone that's not on this list i think
so too i think so i mean
mike pompeo might be again he's a
gangster that's not cia i think he'd go
with nikki haley for sure
i don't really think he's gonna go with
anybody anybody on this list
by the way fyi just just so everybody
knows guys just so everybody knows
um
the next two years of media on this
topic is going to be bonkers okay
the next two years this is gonna be the
ultimate super bowl of super bowls
you're talking afc nfc wwf it's gonna be
so freaking nasty i can't wait so
and nasty
it's great for tv big time yeah i'm
saying so
we're gonna get nasty next couple years
here's the question is nasty good for
america i want what's good for america
no but cnn for cnn and them to come back
out of the freaking grave they need that
they need this let's go to a couple
other stores real quick
i've heard this come up twice now that
voters are lazy and i want to address
this
why do you think
mark zuckerberg dumped 150 or whatever
how many hundreds of millions of dollars
into a get out the vote campaign pushing
everybody to vote go vote go vote go
vote go vote go vote because people
don't do their research they vote for
who they're told to vote for i don't
think they have a big opinion yeah i
think that's exactly why i i don't think
voters are lazy but i don't think
politics is the topic but but wait a
minute let's unpack that my friend tyler
here so
i think
majority are lazy
but the minority is going to determine
the next president and if you got a
million people who flipped you don't
need everybody that's a million people
who flipped that's the truth
a million who flipped okay
is trump good at making allies what's
his resume show and him creating allies
who's who's fired more people on his own
administration than him i don't know a
lot of people okay so that tv show was
not a show
that's
that's him okay
so so if if he's gonna go
a person needs to get in there to give
that side of marketing storytelling
if he continues with this part about you
know it's not fair it's not fair it's
not fair he's got three to six months to
make changes i think three to six months
later it's gonna be
who's gonna be pushed i think in as of
right now i actually agree with the way
it is today i think this thing can flip
in six to twelve months and it can flip
very quickly in what regard flip it uh
flip meaning if he goes
people are not inspired by feel sorry
for me
people are not inspired by it's not fair
that's not an inspirational message
people are not inspired by an
entitlement message
and his messaging is i deserve to be
there right now it's just listen it's
not attractive go fight and win it again
and
change your approach like now when
people are struggling so much with like
inflation with like basic basic needs
they could both think that he look that
he won and it was unfair and feel like
why are you why is he not feeling sorry
for me why am i being asked to expend
pity on this person who's a millionaire
and i can't afford to fill up my car
with gas i think that that's the that's
really important this is like the
easiest time for him to just say i have
nothing to say this is all thing i will
tell you a month before kovit here was
the economy before after and say nothing
else
just do that and show that the
powerpoint of every speech he would give
if i was his campaign manager the next
three six twelve months i'm gonna say
the following look
let's move on with what happened with
2016 20 uh 2020 election forget about it
let's move on with my conflicts with
pence let's move on with all that stuff
this is all i will tell you
this is me pre-covered what america was
like this is you today how do you feel
about it how are you being impacted by
it forget about if you don't like me
because i'm pompous and i'm loud and i'm
this i'm from new york this is my dna if
you've been in the real estate world and
you know how it is to compete this is
how you have to be to compete i've been
like this for 77 78 years it's what's
helped me get here this is how i got
here but forget about set aside your
emotions you don't like me okay for me
being allowed how do you feel about this
you know math you don't need to know
science to see this what do you like do
you like this or do you like this when i
was in what did you hear about isis what
did you hear about this what did you
hear about that what happened here our
administration did a better job with
this theirs is not you want this
continue if you don't
we're coming back and if you want this
if he took that approach a lot of the
people that would hate him they would go
like this
i like this guy but listen i'm like i
got to give him credit yep
he's showing i got to give him credit
if he can't get out of his own way he's
screwed you got six months by the way
you only have six months
you only have six months to flip that
and let me i wanna have two two other
stories before we wrap up one of them is
a newsweek story i gotta give credit to
newsweek since you're part of newsweek
vladimir putin to be called ruler of
russia under new proposal a pro kremlin
party is calling for vladimir putin to
be referred to as the russia
russia's ruler rather than a russia
president in order to move away from job
description derived from a foreign
language the national
liberal democratic party uh proposed
replacing the term president with the
pavitel which means ruler because the
term president has not yet taken root
completely in russia when uh state-run
outlet ria novosti reported dell dpr
said that the using of the term
president has always been embarrassed
embarrassed us the party argued in its
proposal that the term was first used at
the end of 18th century in the u.s and
much later it spread throughout the
world
since this is newsweek what's this all
about with ruler there it is how do you
feel about this all right i i feel about
this the way i feel about a lot of the
coverage of putin which is that you know
the guy is a thug the guy is a murderer
he has you know russia is not a real
democracy
but at the same time i feel like there's
a kind of unhealthy obsession and a need
to make him
much bigger than he is
in the media and in american politics
and i think that that is connected to
trump i mean this is a new thing in
american politics i think our greatest
adversary is china and i don't
understand why we haven't been trying to
make alliances with russia which was
more democratic before we took this
adversarial approach
um you know in in in in an alliance
against china which is actually our
greatest adversary i think russia is
like yeah the war in ukraine is horrible
it's it's devastating but the same time
that doesn't make russia more than it is
which is essentially a petrol state and
we've screwed over our own working class
and our and americans and americans
pocketbooks and their ability to achieve
our middle class life um by taking a
side too strongly in this conflict so
that's how i see it you know i'm not
this is not praise for putin he's a thug
and a murderer
the war in ukraine was absolutely
unjustifiable but at the same time you
know we have a lot of culpability there
we have not done the most that we could
to make sure that things did not end up
here and i think that we've actually
screwed ourselves over when it comes to
fighting china which is a much bigger
threat
[Music]
well i you
check check check everything you said i
totally agree with
um you hit the nail on the head i think
the famous quote is russia is a gas
station masquerading as a country yeah
and you called it a petrol state i i'll
never forget the conversation we had
with the great director oliver stone
here and i was like who does putin want
to be you know stalin lennon he goes no
no no you got to go further back and he
said he wants to be peter the great
and now this just kind of confirms all
that where he wants to be called the
ruler
the president is no longer so in my mind
he's more of an eve on the terrible than
peter the great but um this is this is
and then the last point is i i we need
to refocus
our agenda away from the russian
nonsense and focus more on china we talk
about
that's our biggest adversary but for
50 years it was russia and we've slowly
seen china yeah
you know become the number one
potentially number two country in the
world right now behind the u.s
i think they're set to take us over gdp
wise by what 2030 and that's where our
focus needs to shift so i'm not unders
i'm not completely sure why we're so
focused on russia
it's uh we can maybe can't just shake it
from our dna from the last 50 years i
don't know listen to to make it into
russian politics for as long as this
guy's made it he's not a dummy he's
doing this for a reason
from the outside you may sit there and
say what a terrible timing to do this
because you're allowing the world to say
look how egotistical you are to be
called a ruler there's a motive behind
it the world's gonna find out in about
two to four weeks on the real reason why
they want to make this transition
uh who knows what the reasoning is but
it doesn't show me that it's progressive
it shows me that it's kind of
using this crisis as a way to go
backwards to give even more control to
him
than going in the direction where the
people are really uh in charge of that
country it's just saying no you know
you're right they're not in charge of
country but look at the end of the day
the last two years we've definitely not
worked on strengthening this
relationship at all
so we did not get uh
you know closer to our enemy to calm
them down
we've actually screwed this thing up and
we're spending too much time high-fiving
and uh what do you call it fist-bumping
guys from saudi arabia hey what's up
doug you know hey yeah i know you guys
killed that one journal it's all good
don't worry about how you doing it's a
very weird uh foreign policy approach
that we're taking it's quite
embarrassing if you think about it to
the world on how they're viewing us i
want to wrap up with this one story and
then we'll go into the jimbo thing i
don't know if we have time for it but
i'm going to do it anyway so socialist
exodus in colombia
investments a socialist exodus in
colombia invested halted investments
halted and businessmen flee to miami
after left-wing candidate gustavo petro
triumphed in the second round of
colombia's presidential election on june
19 businessmen across the country began
shifting their savings into dollars and
halted their investment plans instead
entrepreneurs are looking to miami or
panama to expand their businesses to
survive the impending economic chaos
petrol a former gorilla came to the
elections proposing socialist and
populist proposals such as the banning
of
hydrocarbons and fracking massive taxes
and takeovers of unproductive lands
which were raised under the euphemism of
democratization of properties all these
measures resurrecting colombia's the
ghost of chavismo and leftist
governments in latin america which have
left economic crisis in their countries
thoughts
um well to me i'm going to think about
this from like a domestic point of view
like you want to know why hispanic
voters are flocking to the republican
party
it's because of stuff like this you know
the reason that minorities are
increasingly
seeing you know a future for themselves
in the republican party instead of the
democratic party is because
they know what authoritarian looks like
they authoritarianism looks like they
know what socialism looks like in
practice and when things like this
happen you know when they look to the
south america look to central america
and they see you know the things that
their parents told them about their
ancestors told them about you know it
really makes them i think feel some type
of way about democrats um who are
speaking in the same kind of language as
as these people that their families fled
to come to the greatest nation on earth
check out this article by the way tyler
just pulled up get your money out now
miami brokers target colombian buyers
after left this election what a great
strategy by the way adam you got
thoughts no i just sent tyler that
article because look i'm born and raised
in miami i have a lot of colombian
venezuelan
brazilian argentinian friends and i had
a conversation with um a colombian
friend of mine recently and he says
every night
wealthy and even the not so wealthy
colombians sit down and they talk about
their plan b
every night they sit down they say plan
b
is when [ __ ] hits the fan here and it's
happening is
we move to miami
and on someone who lives in miami
that is a fan of the colombian women
they're nice people
come on down but a lot of real estate
brokers in miami they're exactly what
they're saying they say get your money
out now
and take your assets and come live in
miami and that's exactly what's
happening pat made one last note well
you know you guys are talking stuff and
it's just that i think i'm a marxist now
because of bhatia so now i think i'm
switching over because how how how dope
was she as a as a as a guest she's
amazing she's awesome
it's great to have you on i want to wrap
this up with uh
a message for some of you guys with this
picture up here that's my dog the one to
the right jimbo
jimbo has been missing for two days now
okay we went out to dinner on saturday
night with the kids we came back both of
them got out
kuchi to the left was found jimbo to the
right was not found
and uh we've uh that same night i got on
jet ski i went around the community to
see if he fell in the water because that
one time he fell i want to got him not
there
and we had the security camera to see if
he got out of the community this is
north fort lauderdale area he did not
uh so
if anybody sees that dog jimbo on the
caller is my phone number you should be
able to get a hold of me
and if you do you're in a north fort
lauderdale area i'm gonna give a finders
fee of five thousand dollars if you do
find jimbo
this guy's been my uh
best buddy since i started the insurance
company 13 years ago they're pretty much
our first kids before we had kids
uh i would love to see this guy come
back the kids are not yet i love my
oldest son tico still being very
optimistic saying he's gonna come he's
gonna come and it's great seeing their
attitudes on how they're handling this
we're going through this uh because if
you have a dog you know what it is to
have a dog so again
if you know anybody in north fort
lauderdale area his name is jimbo he
looks like that five thousand dollar
finders fee you can either send us an
email info valuetainment.com or text me
on the number that's on his caller
uh jimbo north fort lauderdale area
thanks for listening guys
uh tyler go ahead you have a big thing
coming up tonight what's that oh yeah
tonight i'm doing a real estate uh
bubble webinar if you haven't yet signed
up there's 20 000 people that have
already registered for wow and the
capacity is only 5 000 and last time we
hit 5000 within the first five minutes
so
if you haven't yet registered put the
link below to go get registered to it
we've done weeks of research hours and
hours of research and it's a if you
watch the dave ramsey market crash video
this is a different perspective on the
market crash video
with a ton of data and then you can make
up for yourself what you want to do
there's a lot of folks in the real
estate uh industry mortgage industry
title furniture escrow construction that
are curious and there's people that are
not in the industry that are curious you
may want to get on that webinar at the
end of it i'm going to give you a 20 30
page pdf of all the things we talk about
on tonight's webinar at 5 30 p.m eastern
standard time put the link below in chat
in the
description for uh for people to log on
to last but not least uh if you love the
our guest today as much as we love
bhatia go ahead and purchase your book
uh well bad news how woke media is
undermining democracy
and uh you know if you really enjoy the
debates the back i mean fraud i think we
started debating from five minutes in
here right it was not even hello hey i
disagree it was awesome if you like that
format give us a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel you're awesome looking
forward to having you back again thank
you everybody bye bye bye bye bye
you